hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 11 video so
we found out all about where Aaron's
from got to see couple pictures and a
tease for where the show is gonna be
heading in the next couple of episodes
there was also a couple really awesome
comic book moments that I'll explain as
we go along I was kind of surprised they
aired this episode even though the
Oscars are going on tonight but they do
always air it against really big
football games and Walking Dead
consistently beats football so I think
it has a pretty good shot against the
Oscars - okay so starting with top five
moments careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet here we go
number five
Rick interrogate Sharon right off the
bat Rick isn't gonna trust anyone no
matter what they say erin was doomed
from the start it was really Michonne
that turned them all around you know if
one tells you to chill you have serious
issues the opening credits slam was so
much fun - Aaron's just going on and on
and on about the quote-unquote community
Rick BAM punches him right in the face I
don't trust anyone who smiles after
getting punched in the face in Rick's
defense Aaron did have a pretty creepy
vibe coming off in the first on to
number four Aaron's back story explained
Aaron explains that he used to work for
an NGO just giving medicine to really
impoverished areas in third-world
countries
so he's dealt with warlords pirates so
this is just another Sunday for him no
big deal
probably the best part in their
back-and-forth was when he was trying to
explain how his mother mistreated him by
forcing him to eat applesauce he buried
the lede a little bit when he said his
mom was well-meaning but confused he
doesn't go into super great detail but
it sounds like his mom did crazy stuff
to try and get him to stop being gay
given the list of bad Walking Dead
parents that we've heard about so far I
still think that Daryl's takes the cake
Daryl and Merle zs-- dad still sounds
like the worst parent ever you guys can
let me know what you think who do you
think the worst parent that we've heard
about on Walking Dead so far is is it
one of the survivors parents or is it
like a character we've actually seen on
the show moving on to number three the
group takes an alternate route to get to
the safe zone even if you haven't read
the comics just the general vibe coming
off of Michonne and Rick made it seem
like this episode was gonna be an
example of a negative effects of not
trusting people
Rick reminded her of Woodbury and
terminus both places that seemed nice at
first but then turned out to be really
terrible so he's not ready to chill out
just yet but turns out route 23 not such
a great idea which is
actually our first big comic book moment
I mean Aaron's a big comic book moment
him coming into the story but he came in
at the end of last week's episode it was
a little different in the comics so what
happened is is they basically they took
a car that looked just like that or kind
of like that down this giant hill and
they had to plow through this army of
walkers Abraham was shooting walkers
from the back but it's the same basic
idea it's them flying through a bunch of
walkers just explain why Aaron flipped
out when he saw the road flare the road
flare is meant to signify that the worst
possible scenario has happened it's
meant to be a measure of last resort so
when Aaron saw that he knew that
something really awful had happened to
arrack moving on to number 2 Rick's
group fights through the woods in the
middle of the night this is like a
classic horror film especially with the
moonlight just glowing above them my
favorite effects scene hands down from
the last couple of episodes is Rick
shooting that flare into the walkers
head it's like a walker jack-o'-lantern
any time they locked the camera off like
that and they focus on a particular
scene for longer than a couple of
seconds you know something really big is
gonna happen
so whenever the camera just stayed on
that Walker head while it's sort of
glowing I was like okay this is clearly
meant to be a big effect sequence it's a
good example of the really awesome stuff
they can do with a really small amount
of money I mean it's really expensive to
shoot an episode of The Walking Dead
but effects like this they can they can
do on the cheap and they wanted us to
think that Glenn was gonna back up into
that Walker but when they focus on the
scene that much you start to expect a
twist like it's like okay they want us
to think he's gonna get bit there's
gonna be a twist the twist is most
likely that he will get away usually
when someone dies like Tyreese for
instance getting bitten it's something
you don't expect something you don't see
coming that's why I was more worried
about Abraham getting bit whenever
Rosita held him earlier in the episode
whatever they shared that moment and my
number one moment of course the group
reaches the Alexandria safe zone just to
explain that other new person we met
Erik he's also straight out of the
comics he and Aaron go out and find new
people to bring back to the safe zone I
know a lot of people are saying that
they're the first gay couple on the show
technically that's not true because Tara
had something of a girlfriend whenever
they first met the governor´s group
there's just an unconsummated
relationship so technically tears the
first LGBT character it's just that she
hasn't had any sexual moments on camera
based on all the really positive music
cues it seems like a really good thing
that they're heading to the safe zone
it's like the last minute of the episode
everyone's just holding their breath
waiting to see what's on the other side
of that gate we got a good shot of the
Washington Monument it's the first big
evidence of civilization since Atlanta
it's like oh there's a big city of
people out there but just to put things
into perspective so the safe zone
appeared for the first time in issue 69
negan for example big villain in the
comics didn't appear to issue 100 so
think about this way if it's season 5
and we've only gotten to issue 69 think
about how much story there is before we
get to negan I know everyone's always
asking when they're gonna bring him on
the show they're just there's so many
other new characters that we haven't met
yet
between issue 69 and issue 100 that
we'll probably see that stuff first let
me know what was your favorite moment
from the episode and based on what
you've seen so far what do you think
about the Alexandria safe zone and the
fact that Rick is hiding a gun in a
blender in the teaser for the next
episode it's them just slowly pushing in
you don't see any other people it's just
them just investigating houses so I
think it's gonna be like another week or
two before we start to meet a bunch of
other people if you have read the comics
you're obviously you know who we're
gonna meet next so please use spoiler
tags if you want to talk about him
because we haven't officially gone
inside yet
I'm just gonna wait till next week's
video before I talk about the Alexandria
safe zone in general just remember that
there is a whole bunch of story in the
comics before [ __ ] hits the fan and
negan and the Savior's show up I think
it'll be a nice change of pace for the
show and it'll give them the opportunity
to cycle in a bunch of new characters so
I think it's gonna be the answer to a
lot of people's complaints about the
show getting boring that's just been the
most common complaints I've seen in the
comments is if people just feel like
it's the same thing over and over and
over so now is totally a great time to
jump back on the Walking Dead whole new
area a whole new group of people don't
forget to new round of the giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video I'll announce the winner in
my Q&A video tomorrow I didn't have any
really big thumbs down on the episode
I'll say you know generally things are
picking up the pace is picking back up I
know a lot of people were kind of upset
because not a lot happened in episode 10
but if you're like now shits gonna start
happening so there will be more action
but we obviously we have a bunch of
people that we have to meet in related
news I'm not planning on doing any Oscar
videos but tomorrow I'll be doing my
Walking Dead Q&A and there's a new
episode of Gotham what I'm really
interested to see is how much they're
gonna deviate from the comics it seems
like they're actually they're sticking
pretty close right now but I don't think
they're going to be exactly like what
happened after issue
69 1771 etc so while you guys wait for
the Walking Dead Q&A you can click here
for last week's episode and you can
click here for my latest Game of Thrones
Season 5 video thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I'll see
you guys tomorrow